hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update Bioware has just launched a
survey and they're looking for your help
to make the next Mass Effect game a
producer for the game has tweeted out a
survey that asks gamers several
questions about what they've been
playing recently and what they're
looking forward to most in the next Mass
Effect the survey isn't limited to check
boxes and radio buttons you're asked to
elaborate on your answers giving you the
opportunity to describe your ideal Mass
Effect the survey asks how many hours a
week you play role playing games and to
pick your three favorite RPG activities
with options including combat
discovering new areas exploring
alternative story outcomes customizing
your appearance and several others not
long after the survey was released last
night producer Mike gamble said Bioware
saw an overwhelming response he said he
has reading material for a month but
doesn't want the responses to stop keep
him coming he said the survey also asks
if you'll be attending the San Diego
comic-con in July gamescom in august or
PAX Prime at the end of august and if
you enjoy cosplay if you're eager for
even more news about mass effect the
devs will be on hand at comic-con next
week and we'll be there to get all the
new information as it's released and
posted up here on gamespot com